probably there's been no greater
intervention in the history of human
health than the advent and utilization
of antibiotics for cure of infectious
disease so it's had a tremendous impact
and really sparked the development of
antimicrobial agents not only against
bacteria which penicillin was the
prototype for but also now against fungi
and viruses which plague humans
throughout the world as well in 1942 and
Miller who was the wife of the athletic
director at Yale at the time was ill in
New Haven Hospital with streptococcus
infection in her bloodstream she at the
time there was no antibiotics available
and she had had fevers for several weeks
and then in an effort to try to help her
the chair of physiology John Fulton at
the time who had a relationship with
Howard Florey in the UK who was
developing penicillin for mass
distribution during World War two was
able to actually procure some penicillin
for Miss Miller through doctor floor in
the UK it was shipped to the United
States through Merck and then brought by
a special messenger to New Haven for use
in and Miller to actually arrived on a
Saturday morning she was administered
the drug for the first time and was the
first patient whose life was saved with
penicillin in the United States the next
day she had a complete reduction in her
fever and she survived to the age of 90
having passed away actually in the year
2000 after that Francis Gilman Blake who
was the Dean of the Medical School
actually initiated clinical trials on
several hundred patients with penicillin
after that and it became of course then
much more widespread use today at the
United States and since then well I
think most of the most productive
efforts in trying to reduce the global
burden and infectious disease is by
improving the diagnosis having more
rapid diagnosis
having more widespread access to
antimicrobial agents and more widespread
access to vaccines so the latter two are
certainly highlighted in the HIV
epidemic and in the epidemic of
drug-resistant tuberculosis which is
continuing to spread worldwide so our
efforts on the basis of on on behalf of
our nation and other nations in gaining
access to antiretroviral therapies
globally particularly the sub-saharan
Africa has made a huge impact and more
rapidly diagnosing HIV and diseases like
tuberculosis have made a huge impact in
reducing the total global burden of
those diseases